(zapping)
- [Narrator] Previously on Bro Dependent.
- Since I'm over at your
place all the time anyway,
maybe I could, like,
bring some stuff over.
- Or you could just put an
overnight bag in your car.
- Oh yeah, yeah, that's a great idea too.
- What is this?
- My resume.
- It's five words and a dick.
- Yeah, I drew that.
- I got my eyesight back
and I can see things clearer than ever.
The end, can I go now?
- That was quite good, Zac.
- Oh fuck, did I get it?
(upbeat techno music)
- Oh, fucking sexy, that's very good.
Yes, keep going, keep going.
Oh yes, yes, that's yummy.
We are in the yum zone.
I love this.
Oh my God, you guys are too
good at this, you're too good.
Dane, two seconds,
let's have you step out.
Let's with a couple with Zac and Lexi.
- God bless, great work
everybody, great work.
- Are you fucking for real, dude?
We've been doing this for like 15 minutes.
- Okay, you got somewhere
else you wanna be.
- Yeah, anywhere.
- Hi.
- God, you looked hot out there.
- Oh.
- Okay, let's do some couple photos.
Let's have a little affection in this one.
Let's do some arms around the shoulders.
- Oh no, no, no, no dude.
I can't do that, sorry.
- Why?
- Because, dude, I'm in a
committed ass relationship.
She's right there.
Hey Carolyn.
- Yeah.
- I love you.
- Aww.
- See no can do, dude.
- Zac, Zac, Zac.
- You can't be in here.
No, I'm sorry, I'm so sorry, Martin.
He just burst in,
there was nothing I could do.
- Jesus, we get it,
you can do an Austin Powers impression.
Zac, listen, something huge happened.
- Cool story.
- [Anderson] No, I haven't
told the story yet.
- Marissa, get them off of my set.
- I'm sorry.
You have to leave.
- Do you hear it?
- You're disrupting the shoot.
- Oh yeah, she does
sound like Austin Powers.
- (laughs) Yeah, baby.
- I'm from England.
- Do I make you horny, baby?
- Swing. (laughs)
- One million dollars. (laughs)
- I, Foxxy Cleopatra.
Seriously, that was like
much when my first erection,
was like young Beyonce,
as Foxxy Cleopatra.
- [Zac] I get it.
- I was like, oh, I'm a man now,
(Zac laughs)
thank you.
Can we like, talk, dude?
- (sighs) Fine.
Let's just go over there.
This chick is like obsessed with me.
- Oh, weird.
Dude, I had this kinda,
like, big interview
with Lids the other day
and I kinda blew it, dude.
- Dude, that'd be perfect
for you, you love hats.
- I know, dude, I was so bummed.
I, like, went home and just treated myself
to a consolation bong.
But even that, like,
didn't work out for me.
Like I got all panicky
and I was just like,
Anderson it's not your day,
just switch over to OxyContin.
- Smart.
- Yeah, dude,
and it was great cause like
I couldn't feel anything,
but the thing about Oxy is that
it makes me feel so sluggish
so I like slammed through
those energy drinks.
Have you tried Quatro Crazy?
- Oh my God, dude, I love those.
- [Anderson] Oh yeah, it's the shit, dude.
- [Zac] Yeah, dude, banana bonanza.
- You have an excellent body.
- Oh, bless you.
Get your hands on it, feel it.
- Oh, I'd love to.
- [Zac] So good.
- So anyway, it was working out,
cause I was, like, perfectly numb
but also jacked as fuck--
- Yeah.
- And then my brain was just
like, fucking sell this.
And then, dude, just like
my hands without my brain,
fucking drew this, Quatro
Cotton. (mimics explosions)
(laughs)
- Holy shit, dude.
- I know, dude.
- Zac, seriously, let's
get this over with.
- Oh yeah, you're right.
All right no more photos everybody.
Thank you so much everyone.
- Good day, guys.
Really good work.
- No no, you're not done.
- Ex-fucking-scuse me.
- This is your job, you can't just leave.
- Hey Zac, who am I?
Blah blah blah blah blah,
I have a camera. (laughs)
my dick is a tiny camera.
- You're that dude.
- I'm that guy. (laughs)
- Hey, is your dick a tiny camera?
(Anderson laughs)
- What?
- What, what, what?
- A what?
- What?
- [Anderson] A what?
(both laughing)
- What?
- Click, click.
- Fuck you guys.
(both laugh)
- He's so mad, dude.
That was funny as fuck, dude.
- Yeah, dude, thanks.
- Hey, dude, I've missed this.
- Yeah, me too.
- Hey, do you like sex?
- Yeah.
- Let's go have some.
- Okay.
- So what do you say man,
you wanna get into bed with
Quatro Cotton? (laughs)
- No, dude, I mean, I'd rather
just be business partners.
- Oh yeah, no, that's
even better. (both laugh)
- [Zac] Yeah, dude.
- [Anderson] Nice, let's get outta here.
- All right, Carolyn.
Hey Carolyn?
- That's weird.
It's fine, dude, we can just take my...
I don't know how I got here.
This stuff really works, man.
Like, I have no idea how
I got here. (both laugh)
(upbeat techno music)
- Hey.
- Thanks for watching Bro Dependent,
on Comedy Central's
YouTube channel. (laughs)
It's the est episode ever.
Yeah, comment and subscribe,
and check out more on comedycentral.com
and, dude, we're back.
- We're back.
- We're like... (both laughing)